I felt that I had to miss  but people did not choose to listen to  what I was saying we all understand that  she sat down on the bus the policeman he  said why don't you stand up and say I  don't think I should have to stand there  the narrow Narrative of her just on one  day did something couldn't be further  from the truth  often the man is out front and you never  hear about the wife get the reverse is  true  she was considered a threat espousing  radical views if they could see her  talking about the Republic of new Africa  they're out there with the Panthers then  they would understand the real Rosa  Parks but they might have been just a  little frightened she has been an  activist for over three decades for Miss  Parks it was especially dangerous  fighting on issues that are still very  much at the Forefront she never gave up  she lit the torch to the Next Generation